you're a judge on american idol you have
been you're in that mentorship role
um i actually heard a story that when
you were in the commodores
you were
sort of hesitant to be a front man there
was
is this true
that is so true i listen
to show you how terrified i was
during the freshman talent show when the
curtains opened i literally walked off
with the curtains
and they kept saying lionel the
microphone's right here and so it took
me about maybe five to eight years to
really get comfortable
on stage but i i suffer from a
tremendous amount of stage fright and of
course actually it was the jackson 5
tour that kind of took me out of that
little
little nervousness
i mean what do you
say to people especially since you're in
this mentor you know role on american
idol and you know i'm sure you've had so
many countless
situations where you've spoken to people
uh
is there
something that will set you free or you
have advice on with that
you know i i first of all i got to tell
you with american idol i am having so
much
fun
that you have no idea but our job is to
not scare them to death because we all
put ourselves in their position i can't
imagine
for my first time ever trying to ask
somebody do you like what i do to be on
national television and then
they come out and you can see their lip
or their hands shaking and
and you they're terrified and
i always like to say to them you know
what is the similarity between a hero
and a coward
i'll answer that they were both scared
to death
one step forward and one step back
and i said right now it's okay to be
scared
but just make sure you step forward
i am so glad that i asked you that
question
and
i can't wait
to watch the season premiere on
valentine's day by the way what a
perfect
valentine's galentine's valentine's
whichever you like um i cannot wait and
i was also reading um that there are
actually tweets and twitter phenomenons
and you know things all over the place
about how good you smell
[Laughter]
is that a rumor
in fact listen to this one
um at uh fallout carl tweeted i once was
told by someone who worked for his
management team that lionel richie
smells like sugar cookies it makes
perfect sense what else would lionel
richie smell like
oh wow i've had the um wonderful oh oh
oh yeah
oh oh oh there oh you went there oh yeah
oh no and i fully sprayed like myself on
both sides with uh both scents uh tell
us about this new perfume and cologne
hello
well well drew let me just say this to
you you know everyone kept asking me
over and over again
what are you wearing
and i'm one of those kind of guys i
don't want to smell like everybody else
but at the same time i like to make my
own little concoctions
and so finally someone talked me into
let's make one for you for your
fragrance
and i'm telling you if you can believe
this we were one of the runners-up uh in
the five category of fragrance of the
year
pop culture
how about that so i'm there with kylie
and all the rest of the gang if you like
it
but the thing about it is you know
creating notes
in a fragrance and creating notes in a
song
is pretty much the same concept it's
just that one requires my ears and the
other requires my nose but
it it's something i really enjoy doing
and the fact that it's doing so well is
makes me happy well we love all things
beauty and style here and one more
question i heard your mustache
has some special
um maintenance to it will you give
viewers a tip because i read something
that i didn't know and i loved it well i
i gave away a little bit of a secret
over the years you find yourself i won't
say trapped but spending lots of time in
hotel rooms around the world
and someone gave me a tin
magnification mirror
[Laughter]
oh yes we women know all about that you
know and a tin magnification mirror in a
hotel room
with idle time only creates one thing
what is that hair right there what is
that hair and so you find yourself
tweezing and what
tweezing and it looks pretty even so a
lot of guys sit there and shave i just
tweeze it and it works you know but it's
it's the funniest thing about it it's
just came from idle time
and now that's the secret to everything
i love it i just love talking to you so
much i can't thank you enough hello by
lionel this beautiful successful like
awesome hot brand is out right now and
the new season of american idol
premieres this sunday valentine's day at
8 7 central on abc happy birthday thank
you so much
big kiss
[Music]
you